so hi folks can everyone hear me at the
back okay this is all working super so
thank you very much to the organizers
and volunteers for inviting me to come
and talk to you my name is rhea miguel
Forte I am half Greek half Portuguese I
live in Athens a few words about me I
before starting to work in this sort of
the HR space I've been involved in
language optimization for marketing
specifically with mobile promotions and
in educational gaming in Athens some of
the things I do and you can find me I
run the data science Athens meetup group
I'm an author of mastering predictive
analytics with R and I'm actually giving
a few copies away next tomorrow at
lunchtime and I also teach at the
business analytics program in the Athens
University of Economics and business
so the basic my basic goal today in this
talk sorry yes tomorrow at lunch yeah
tomorrow at lunch
yeah yeah yeah so yeah I'm doing this
tomorrow at lunch so yeah so the I've
got two main goals with this talk the
first thing is to give you a good sense
of why the HR space is actually very
interesting and very ripe for data
science the second thing is I want to
focus on the data and give you a sense
of how working with unstructured data
and Sun structured text has a lot of
interesting various has a lot of
interesting challenges and the kinds of
basically kind of give you the kinds of
tips and tricks that we've sort of
learned the hard way over sort of
working with with these with his data
over the past two three years so I work
at workable we're a start-up were formed
in 2012 basically what we do is we offer
a SAS platform for hiring ok so we work
with small and medium businesses and we
provide them a service where you know
they can go and post the job to
different job boards and sort of have
that on their website and candidates
come in and the applying for this
particular job and then the various
hiring managers they interact with these
candidates so they set up appointments
and they receive information about them
through for instance CVS and eventually
through moving the through stages some
people get hired some people do not so
this actually as a situation in terms of
data we have very interesting things to
look at we have essentially data of
millions of candidates around the world
applying to hundreds of thousands of
jobs and basically some of them doing
well some of them are not doing so well
and all of this across different
different places around the world and in
different industries so obviously for us
this presents a lot of opportunities to
do data science you can do things and
I've listed some of the some of the
things that doing obviously I'm not
gonna be covering all of these in my
talk my my focus on those is on the CV
but a lot of things that we can be doing
is obviously sort of recommender systems
they're trying to figure out if there's
a way from the information that comes
with an application so the actual the
actual candidate profile can you match
this to a job other things are for
example dealing with sponsor fraud
detection some people try and advertise
or post the job that isn't really a job
it is some attempt to maybe sort of
identity theft or post something you're
not supposed to like money mewling or
something like that so they're different
there are different kind of areas here
that we could we can touch upon and for
this talk I wanted to talk to
specifically of primarily rather about
the problem of how do you deal with the
fact that information about candidates
often comes in the form of a CV which is
unstructured and I will I will cap it
off with a little bit about duplicate
detection so the first thing I want to
talk about is why even bother with this
problem right I mean nowadays most
people when they apply for a job they do
one of two things they either link up
their LinkedIn profile which is nicely
structured okay or they fill in an
online form which the company has
provided and they which can easily be
customized to the current to the
company's needs
the truth is that the CV isn't dead
basically the first thing right I mean
many many recruiters use the CV because
it allows them to office Kate candidate
details so you essentially still have
the person's academic trajectory and
their work trajectory but you hide how
to contact them for obvious reasons a
lot of clients we work with and a lot of
people in the HR I mean the HR vertical
in general is an industry that isn't
sort of if you were to sort of rank
different in
and how far they are in the tech space
HR tends to lag so a lot of people who
work with human resources might not be
particularly tech savvy and a lot of
people still don't use sort of online
platforms like us so for example a very
classic situation that we've come into
is that a lot of clients that join and a
lot of people that become our clients
don't join from another 80s obviously
that is there is a use case but Lauren
must often because the market is very
unsaturated you get a lot of people that
work with CDs right they have some
folder on their desktop with a lot of
CDs from people who've applied in the
past and they somehow try and search on
their on their on their machine for this
okay and so this leads you to the to the
idea that CD parsing is important so
it's a frequent use case but the other
thing that's super important is that a
lot of the more advanced things like
sort of the recommenders system that I
talked to you about being able to match
cast can make profiles with jobs kind of
relies on the idea that you have a
structured profile out there right so
being being important enough to being
often enough as a use case and also
important to enable other tasks such as
recommender system makes it a suitably
interesting enough topic for for a talk
like this and we've invested a lot of
time thinking about how we might go
about taking any document so a document
could be like a PDF or a docx or ODT and
then passing it through this parser that
automatically gets some of the important
information about a candidate now what
are we actually looking for here
obviously what people put on their CVS
is a lot of different different stuff
right at its core and for for in order
to power sort of the basic sort of
beginning process of hiring which is
like maybe a screening call we would and
being able to be sort of well searchable
what we'd like to do is we'd like to get
things like another person's name how to
contact them so this could be involved
sort of like phone or email information
basically where they've studied the kind
of degrees they have and where they've
worked
we also inclusive skills and social
network profiles and I will mention
social networking profiles a little bit
more later on down the line
so this task is kind of fairly complex
so obviously what we'd like to do is
kind of break it up into chunks and this
is kind this is in a nutshell I've tried
to sort of give you a global picture of
the process that we follow we start from
basically getting the document that
comes in and analyzing it so the content
analysis is basically can I get the text
out of this document then you have to do
some pre-processing with the text the
text is very unstructured very dirty and
then we try and figure out can we break
up this this text that we get from a CV
into sections and then within these
sections think about what role each
sentence plays and then looking within
each sentence can we look at the
particular entities so the named entity
recognition task becomes very important
because you're looking for things like
degrees and names of companies and job
titles right and ultimately using all of
this information to construct a profile
and then of course you have a post
profile sort of a post-processing kind
of cleaning step so that's really the
process in a nutshell that we follow for
content analysis we use Apache tikka
which you found to be sort of sort of
really good project gets regularly
updated they have release cycles of it's
not very regular but very frequent
rather so even less than six months I
recently saw on their website that they
were involved in in technology for
analyzing the Panama papers which is
quite interesting so with we go back to
series what does tika do for us
essentially it allows us to do these
three things right it allows us to just
extract the text from from from any
arbitrary document so it has an auto
detecting parser inside that kind of
detects what kind of document you have
it then extracts some metadata for us
and that's quite interesting often
documents come up with metadata such as
you know author information as well as
tags of images that might be embedded
inside and we also can it can extract
embedded images this is actually powers
related but very useful feature that if
you some people would like to somewhat
rather some candidates include a photo
of themselves in their CV and so an
application right now you can actually
drag your CV and it will if you included
your own photo in there then your avatar
will be automatically and created from
that so take is actually really good at
sort of helping us do this of course we
have a separate face that
component as well to make sure that we
don't actually drag some random graphic
that is in there but it helps you the
actual extraction from the embedded
images so for data privacy reasons I can
actually show you some a lot of
real-life Seavey's here so what I'd like
to do is I'd like to give you just a
small section from a person CV and they
do apology if it's a little bit hazy so
here's a here's an example of a CV I'm
sure we've all we've all written them at
some point horrible experience for all
of us so this is an education section
this is a work experience section seeing
that you know they're using a table here
non standard formatting very sort of
pretty run-of-the-mill stuff for CVS
what happens when you extract the text
from this even with the state-of-the-art
tool like tika is that you have a lot of
different effects that actually sort of
mess up your text right you see that the
you obviously don't have the table
anymore and actually what you see in the
top left here is you've seen that what
tika has done is it's taken the first
column and scanned it and then it's
taken the second column is scanned it
and then the third column and scanned it
right and this is obviously not very
useful for us because what we'd like to
do when we looking at something like
this is actually read it row wise okay
so we can actually get because this is
one educational entry this is another
educational entry and this is the third
educational entry small tip here if you
are writing a series and you expect your
CV to be parsed by a bot or a program
like like ours then make sure you do not
use tables write tables are the devil
for this so I've listed here some kind
of effects that you get with text
extraction so obviously as I said you
may have things that come out of order
and basically if sentences get split up
which is the example I've showed for
education and she's this is quite bad
because it's very difficult to associate
and find that you know this particular
date that is roll away up here is
actually associated with this university
and this subject and all these make a
particular education entry right it's
also bad if they if we the entire
sentences sort of jump shot a jump
section because you're probably going to
think that they're playing a different
role in the CV that you're analyzing
okay you've got things like headers and
footers which may repeat and they can
sort of you can find them interspersed
within the text that you have you lose a
lot
the lay-up mark-up information okay and
you have a whole load of interesting and
exciting things that happen with
characters right from accents being
altered repeated spacing out especially
you know people who use sort of word art
or things like that in Mississippi's
graphic designers right graphic
designers these people are the worst
okay anybody here a graphic designer
did I get into trouble I'm so sorry I
love you guys
but when it comes to series sort of
graphic designers will use the CB as
like a canvas of their creativity okay
and this just totally wrecks havoc when
you try and extract the text out of it
so basically trying to mitigate this is
a problem it's very difficult to
actually automatically detect if a CV
that's been extracted in this way you
sort of using this tool actually is
incorrect and there's something that
something that has gone sort of badly
there are certain cases where you might
try and do something so one thing that
we tend to do is we're trying to find
sentences that have regularly spaced out
individual letters and see if we can
actually compress them sort of this this
if I was if this is a resort of my name
sort of with multiple spaces in between
so if you reduce the spaces in a
predictable way you might actually end
up with a corrected version detecting
badly extracted tables is something I'm
sort of I'm looking at but I haven't I
haven't got a good idea of this I think
you have some idea of how to do this and
I really want to pick your brain about
that at some point okay let's move on to
text pre-processing so at this point
we've extracted the text so doesn't
matter what document type this came from
you extract the text and you have
basically a typical NLP pipeline right
you've got us you've got standard sort
of language processing tasks which
always begin by sort of making sure that
you clean the data in some way and then
you start thinking about can I sort of
break it up into sentences and then
break it up into words and maybe find
the parts of speech that these words and
this is the reason why you do this early
on is that a lot of the other and more
intelligent things that you want to do
further down the line usually rely on
these things as features right so
knowing whether something is a noun or
not sort of can help you figure out
whether it might be you know the name of
a company or a person for example
right obviously the the key point I want
to pass here is that these these are
sort of low-level natural language
processing problems or things that you
read in academic texts that tell you
that the accuracy is 97 98 whatever
percent when you give it text that is
coming from real real life non
professionally written sort of documents
that have been extracted as well what
you end up seeing is that the accuracy
is not particularly good especially with
more complex things such as dependency
parsing and current chart and chunking
so and the reason for this is that most
of the most of the academic sort of
models that you find the most with the
pre trend models that you find out there
have been trained on sort of
grammatically correct sort of curated
corpora and of course everybody knows
and Seavey's you have typos you've got
you also have this this effect where
you've got all of headlines right verbs
are relatively rare in a CV because
you've got lots of different headlines
and incomplete sentences out there like
listing of skills for example or a sort
of work experience headlines and you
also have a very large a much larger
proportion of proper nouns which sort of
is one of the difficult areas that a lot
of these tools struggle to or perform
well and there's a large proportion of
proper nouns right names of companies
names of people names of products tools
skills sentence splitting is also very
tricky right because what you want to do
things is you want to actually break it
down so that you can actually understand
and separate out some of the sentences
that are you know that are distinct in
terms of headers but you also want to
keep certain related entities together
and of course training these models is
difficult and expensive to do it on your
own so what we end up doing is we end up
relying on a lot of these sort of openly
available models such as like open NLP
or more Stanford's core NLP and just
have to bear and carry this error that
comes with with them but we know that
this is what the key takeaway here is
that to know that you know this this
thing is already the features that
you're going to use in subsequent models
are going to be dirty now under section
identification
actually the most regular aspect of a CV
the thing that you at least expect
graphic designers notwithstanding though
but the thing that you would least
expect that you must expect to happen is
that this is a document that has certain
sections and I expect certain of these
sections to be named in a particular way
okay this is probably the most regular
thing and the most general thing I can
say about series because believe you me
I have seen everything so here is a
here's an example of a CV so how many of
you watch this show called Game of
Thrones okay the rest of you what are
you doing with later in life no I'm
kidding okay so this is a character from
Game of Thrones that probably those of
you who watch it will find this probably
amusing I the main point I want to I
want to show here is that generally what
you expect to find a CV is some section
that has sort of education followed or
preceded by some section with an
experience and maybe some summary or
possibly some contact details under the
person's name okay
this of course is with the prototypical
sort of CV situation and you know the
first thing we tried understanding and
parsing when we started doing this and
they later require that it's such a
small percentage of things that you
actually have to very quickly abandon
and sort of move on to something a lot
more advanced even though it's pretty
much what you wouldn't you know sort of
or you would expect and there are two
key ideas behind section identification
right the first thing is even though
you're actually interested in very few
sections right the information you want
the the details I told you that we're
looking for is actually concentrated in
just a few sections right you want to
know where the education section is and
where the experience section is because
we're not really at this point trying to
look at things like interests hobbies
societies research interests and a whole
lot of other things that people put on
their CV right so generally you're
looking for only a few sections but in
order to know to do this task the chunk
your CV into different sections you need
to know where section ends and where
does one section end where another
begins so you actually need to be able
to figure out where you need to know
about other other kinds of center of
sections as well
the second key idea is all right
this could be a great feature on its own
even if this is the only thing you do
you can actually get value of this if
you build a good section identifier for
for for unstructured documents such as
CVS this is actually useful for two
reasons the first thing is it could help
computer assisted data entry if you just
highlight the CV and help the person
who's made move manually trying to put
in the correct information you can just
highlight where you think a particular
section is the second thing is that you
can actually achieve better search
because you normally tend to weight
terms that appear in particular sections
more or less depending on their
significance to whatever you're looking
for right how do we solve this problem
so good old regular expressions we have
basically seen and looked at a lot of
different examples of CVS and for
various different sections we get amount
of a very high accuracy just by forming
regular expressions too to fill out all
the different combinations of what
people do now I have seen there is a
caveat I have seen sections where there
you know that the titles are things like
where I've been and what I've done in an
attempt to be amusing I hope this person
hasn't sent the CV to IG I'm gonna get
into trouble today but at any rate so
obviously you're not going to capture
this okay but you are gonna get a very
high accuracy without having to do
anything machine learning related so
here's an example so that this will this
very simple obviously okay in reality of
the regular expressions we have a lot
more complex they have a lot more
different we've we've seen a lot more
different examples but this thing would
capture something like in a tertiary
with a space education or educational
space qualifications for example or just
education on its own here this is
optional so okay so you you break down
the CV and you think about different
sections and then you want the way we
try and approach finding the information
we want is again we say that just like
with sections there are only very few
sentences inside this document that
actually have the information we want
most of the text inside the CV is
actually explanatory and supportive of
particular headlines why did people
generally write let's say their work
experience they have a header like data
scientist at workable so and so and so
and so to show date
and beneath it they write several
sentences worth of explanations what the
person who's doing the skills they use
the tools they used and sort of more
about it so that that is actually a lot
more text then just the simple headline
and the headline is what you want so
being able to identify headlines is very
important so we have designed a sentence
classification task where we kind of
we're what we're trying to do is a
multi-way classification look at
sentences and classify them into one of
these labels things like work experience
education contact detail skills and
everything else so we models we've
currently have significant success with
we're doing this is sort of standard
sort of linear SVM's
most of the features we use at this
point are things like you know the sort
of pause features so if it hasn't if it
doesn't have a verb in it it's a good
chance that this thing is a header
things like you know a particular words
that you might be interested in so
bag-of-words features are very prevalent
obviously what section you can find it
in things like the general shape of the
sentence what are the distribution of
spaces if it has lots of tabs for
example it's a good hint that this is a
this is a header because a lot of the
headers tend to have lots of tabs this
is the kind of information you really
sort of glean by actually looking at a
lot of examples of the data right if you
want to deal with unstructured text
nothing compares to sitting down and
seeing lots and spending lots of time
looking at particular examples and the
next step is basically once you have the
sentences you want you want to be able
to do to identify entities right so you
have this named entity recognition task
which is essentially finding you know
specific entities of interest so here's
an example so I've labeled in blue sort
of a job done if this is a header you
could say that you know this is a job
title this is a date this is the date
and this is an organization and actually
this example in of itself is a good way
for you to see why this is actually a
non-trivial problem some people might
say that only this part here is the job
title this is actually the name of a
department and some might say that you
might want this to be one single date as
a date range some people might say that
this marker here although the co is a
marker that helps you understand that
this is
this is a company might only want this
term so this gives you an idea one of
many reasons why this is actually a
non-trivial problem to work on and as
you'll see a non-profit reveal problem
to annotate with so we have actually had
little moderate to quite little success
using existing tools right you existing
open NLP tools you throw in unstructured
text from CVS and this thing most of the
models will give you junk right in terms
of entities they will find companies and
think there are people they will find
skills and think they are companies and
all kinds of combinations that you don't
want happening and it is fairly
reasonable if you think about it right
because the corpus that they've been
trained on the examples that they've
been given is high quality text often
from a different domain and the other
problem is most of the time they don't
even have the particular labels we want
the labels we want are specific to the
academics / work experience kind of
trajectory that a person has right
things like degree type subjects job
titles along with a more familiar kind
of locations and people's names and
we're gonna a names of organizations
right so the way we went around this is
that we build we've built a very simple
rule base ten-yard by hand this is a
mixture of regular expressions and
lookup lists and I'll be honest you can
get a lot of the way there tuning tuning
your regular expressions is very
important just as how building carefully
building your look-up list is also very
important because by doing those things
you're essentially tuning in sort of
your precision and recall and what we've
definitely found is that companies are
by far the hardest entity to correctly
identify and of course for this task we
can also we can also use and how we have
rules that incorporate knowledge of what
section the particular sentence is in at
this time we are also running a very
interesting project in which we're
building an annotated corpus right so
what we're doing is we want to build our
own named entity recognition model with
machine learning I don't I need to have
the time nor sort of nor nor the goal to
go into details of the sort of
sequence prediction models and there
they aren't that important at this point
the main thing to do and the very
interesting sort of insights that we've
had has been on the actual annotation
process and I want to talk to you a
little bit about that because I rarely
see talks that where people talk about
this and we start from the idea that you
know you have feature design is super
critical you're going to start with very
even with very noisy input features and
it's actually a very difficult task as
well just to get the correct labels
right because you've got if you think
about the named entity recognition task
you need to get the correct span of
words and the correct label so in a
nutshell our basic approach is we focus
on this we have a lot of redundancy we
have three people who have been trained
over a period of time and they're all
annotating the same things our approach
has been get fewer data but make sure
that you have triple annotated so we can
use things like majority voting to
actually error correct as we go along
and another good idea that we found to
do is because you obviously learn as you
go along a good idea to do is to split
your training data in batches so if you
change your conventions if you realize
that I should be labeling this thing
differently or I should have a different
category whatever you actually know
exactly when you changed your convention
maintaining documentation is super
important in this protein in this
process and the other thing is start
building models early right you're not
gonna get good accuracy it's not gonna
be great but you are going to start
realizing the areas or maybe particular
labels where things aren't working okay
and this can actually build up your
expectations and you can make learning
curves to get a sense of whether you're
sort of getting more data helps you and
is likely to give sort of better
accuracy I'll quickly say a few things
about extracting skills this is actually
getting understanding a person's skills
from from an unstructured document is
actually very tricky it's actually very
tricky to define in general and if you
see online different services that have
for example recommendation systems
matching job matching profiles to
candidates you will find that most of
them focus on the IT sector this is
because skills are quite
defined right you can have names of
databases names of programming languages
names of subject areas like machinery
like machine learning and this is this
is quite well defined try to do this for
things like account management for
things like sales or even human
resources it's much harder skills are
far less they're far less well defined
and they're also much far fewer tools
that will allow you to easily identify
from a set of skills a particular
particular job title so you'll see
things like you know journalists might
say newspapers right and meaning this is
kind of metonymy right they mean that
they have experience in writing articles
for newspapers right for a musician
clarinet is a valid skill an HR
professional might say CBS a project
manager sort of out-of-the-box thinking
okay we've all nevermind okay
soft skills right and and building a
taxonomy of skills are building this
large sort of list of all the different
kinds of skills by all four all the
different kind of verticals is a manual
process we are doing it manually if you
guys have thoughts on sort of how to do
this in a better way I'd love to hear
about it but it's very difficult for
example one thing we did is we took all
the unique skills so we have a lot of
people applying from LinkedIn we took
all the unique skills that we found from
this and just by random sampling we
basically see that let fewer than one
and one fewer than one and a hundred are
actually sort of normalized valid skills
that you can use for example typing
skills have are actually are actually
the type of skill that is parameter
izybelle many people write X words per
minute so the X obviously varies based
on your competence and the words per
minute can be written in an amazing
number of different ways so I don't have
that much time I will say that at the
very end if you've come to this point
and you've broken down your problem
right you've annotate you've broken down
into sections you've looked at sentences
you've extracted entities you're almost
all the way there your goal there at
that point is to establish relationships
between the entities to form sort of
work experience items and education
my turns on the one hand and on the
other and you can use sort of a certain
slop filling approaches use what we do
there are of course machine learning
models to establish relations so you can
also do something like that in other
cases we use a machine learning model
for things like candidate name because
what happens there is if you have more
than one name on a CV for example you
know people put their supervisors name
at the University you may have a person
a referee if somebody's giving you a
reference or you may listen the name of
your boss you can impress someone if
your boss is super well known so you may
have certain lots of different names in
your CV I'm a model that tells you ok
which one is the right one yes if the
first one is ohm is very often the right
one but it's it's not it's not often
enough to warrant you're not doing a
model for this don't be lazy and the
sort and the post-processing part that
we do normalization is super important
so we tend to sort of remove certain
stop words and clean up all the text we
try to find standard forms and we also
have a pruning step it throws away kind
of some of the entities that we find
that you know arts are very sparsely
filled and this is like an error
correction step I have some slides here
and that talked a little bit about the
problem of finding duplicate prop
profiles in a nutshell what this problem
has to do is that as as an applicant
tracking system we often get
applications from the same person from
the same job and this isn't as rare as
you might imagine for example you may
see this job a job you're interested in
on indeed and you sort of fill in a form
and yeah and without even looking at the
name of the company and then you've
given your CV to a recruiter and then
they apply and then you don't hear from
them for a week and then you see their
posts than at their website and then you
fill in their form so you can end up
with two or three sort of different
profiles and of course what what what a
good system would do is try and figure
out that this is the same person okay
this is actually a non-trivial task
right because there is no universal
identifier that's always correct okay
and this is for many different reasons
sort of you know fields can change your
fields can have many valid options you
can present information in different
ways and there are some papers and the
Greek government that have my name
written like this
true story
so that is my name transliterated in
greek characters and they're actually
interesting transliteration tools that
we use for in for applicants in Greece
that transliterate names in Greek to
their English equivalent in a nutshell V
approaches normalized I've said it
before normalization on text is super
important you can then compare sort of
names with names and company names with
company names and so on and basically
the real magic is in this part using the
correct type of comparator for the
different field types we'll get will get
you good features there fairly few of
them if you do this part correctly
logistic regression will work like a
charm you don't need anything harder
than that
so to wrap up I wanted to share with you
I have a few slides I'm not sure if I'll
get through all of these but I'll may be
going through them I wanted to share a
few tips and tricks that I've sort of my
team we've collected sort of working
with unstructured text like CVS over the
over time the first thing I mentioned
here is back of words the classic thing
you do with bag-of-words features you
throw away the really frequent ones that
are soft words you throw away the really
rare ones because they also don't have
information you just keep sort of sweet
spot in the middle it turns out you
should also manually check the ones
you're keeping because depending on your
data you might end up including certain
words that I might over fit for example
one thing we discovered was that because
we had a company that had many different
jobs the company's name ended up on this
ended up in this list and obviously this
is not a particularly good feature to
use if you want to generalize a model
for detecting fraudulent job postings
right watch your memory footprint so
when you're classifying classifying
sentences especially if you're using
you're creating a lot of sparse and
binary features things like you know bag
of words features for the words and the
previous sentence in the next sentence
in the current sentence build your
features classify the sentence and move
on don't build the sort of the features
for all the sentences at once this will
this is actually something we did rather
unfortunately in the beginning we were
using massive sort of memory resources
for no reason the other thing is that
don't just straight jump into a mouth
it's fun and sexy try and see if you can
get the way there just by using some
sort of rules or regular expressions
they're easier to maintain if they're
not way too many of them so for example
if you want to fuse data coming in from
different profiles we found we generally
know the rules we want to follow when we
can actually describe these so there's
no reason to go into machine learning
detecting languages and Seabees
everything I've shown you is very
language dependent so this is an
important step it turns out we found a
way that if you just look up certain key
cv related terms this is an excellent
way of detecting the language on the CV
for text normalized normalized
normalized right it makes it easier to
look up it's far better to have a simple
model that works to normalize text as
features rather than you're trying to do
something more complex where you haven't
put in the work to sort of preprocessor
the data properly performance again
incorporated into your design decisions
we for example found random for us which
are all the rage these days
barring but we had marginally better
performance with them from the sentence
classification task they take up a lot
of memory the performance increase was
so this so small that we just didn't
bother another thing that we did is we
had a very powerful deduplication model
that actually incorporated in the
comparators that I spoke to you about
named variants we could actually capture
that Nikolas is nikolaos in Greek and
Pavlov is Pavel in Polish and Jim
isn't-isn't is James Richard dick
they're all these combinations but what
you end up doing is you end up requiring
a massive number of comp of sort of
comparisons at very very very small game
reproducibility is absolutely essential
and reproducibility means three things
you need to keep track of the exact data
you used when you build a model you need
to keep the exact source code you use
and the results you can cross-check
right so if you're not keeping all these
three you're not doing your job right so
I will leave the other four things for
you to read testing has been mentioned
extensively in past Talk's today and yes
we are data scientist but we
do you need to test our code as some of
us have discovered moving on and I
suppose I'm allowed to say that we're
hiring so come talk to me later if you
are interested thank you very much for
your time okay so one minute overboard
that not too bad how do we give the
microphones are yeah okay you well one
of you and then the other one
okay so this the process we have in
production right now so the goal is to
have a fully automated process I have
two things to say about that the first
thing is that we deliver this
incrementally so sort of contact details
social network profiles things like that
that we can accurately capture this this
we released relatively early on we are
we have not released the part that has
with work experiences and education
because we're still working on that part
of the reason is we're building an R on
any our model to kind of improve the
results we're getting the goal is for it
to be automatic because the most classic
use case is not because people want to
do is sister the entry which B which
would be another use case that we will
implement later on the classic use case
is what I mentioned earlier people have
just folders of CVS that they want to
upload quickly and just even have the
names of these people just having the
ability to have a system where you can
search because if you put the CV online
it will be it will be indexed into Soler
if you extract the text and so you can
easily search just having sort of a
database where you have the names of the
people you have plus their contacts and
their CV for more details is is a great
sort of starting point if what you're
working on is just folders so we our
goal is to focus on the fully automated
process right now you had a question
okay I knew that would get me into
trouble I knew I should have said that
aesthetics okay so that's that that's
quite interesting the short answer is no
we haven't tried to capture sort of some
model of what Seavey's sort of visually
look like better than others I would
take a guess that things I would tend to
prefer TVs the kind of get a good sense
based on sort of number of words in a
sentence and so on and the spacing
distribution you if things that come up
well in structured when you when you
extract the text if this is well
structured okay chances are it's a very
well-organized CV and that's super
important so that would actually answer
the aesthetic slash well-organized kind
of component for domains other than
graphic designers I think it's a
completely open problem to see whether
this looks aesthetically pleasing or not
yeah
okay right so I take actually
incorporates tesseract and it does that
automatically for you yeah yeah I mean
so this this is automatically happening
whether it's screened or scanned or not
even with a Word document we sometimes
get this effect where it's it's it's a
table and we just just it just gets
interpreted in the wrong order detecting
that is quite difficult it's difficult
to detect whether a sequence of short
because that was you that's what usually
happens because they're cells of a table
sort of short entries should be
organized into a table because even if
he knew that happened you need to figure
out okay so how many rows at the table
have right so it's actually quite it's
it's a quite a tricky problem yes
PDF minor I've used I text and I can
tell you tickers better but I haven't
tried PDF minor okay okay yeah okay yeah
this that's good
yeah yeah natural is not too far ahead
so we wreck generally the recommendation
approach that we that we're building on
this is just one of the tracks this is
just one of the projects that my team is
working on we do have a separate track
that is purely working on the
recommendation problem and the
recommendation problem what you can do
here if you think about it is that you
have you've got lots of different jobs
and people sort of we have sort of
different pipelines or it's different
stages this is the classic sort of
representation of what happens during
the hiring because hiring process
usually involves you applying and then
maybe getting a screening call maybe a
first interview maybe a second interview
and depending if you're like McKinsey or
whatever it is six seventh interview
whatever and eventually hire no hire
right and with possibilities to sort of
be rejected at several stages so you can
say that somebody who went far along
this stage is a decent applicant for
this job and somebody who wasn't is not
a decent applicant for this job
obviously this is very error-prone there
are two basic assumptions first thing is
that you can actually associate
information on a CV or general
information what did you have in a
candidate profile with their success
there is a signal but you know we all
know it's fairly weak the second thing
is that especially for companies that
have long many people applying some
people did not progress simply because
they apply too late so they their CV is
never even got the gods' same but yes
the goal is to be able to use
information from from our database and
we are working on things like finding
similar jobs so if you open up a
position that it says data science we
have built a model that finds similar
kind of jobs similar sort of data
science related jobs in our database
looks at the kinds of candidates that
did well on these and then tries and
compare then goes and compares these
guys with the people that applying to
the job that you just created to give
you a kind of sense again the goal here
is not to replace it's not to give sort
of detailed and fine-grained rank what
you can generally do is
at least at least capture whether some
certain some typical sort of
requirements are being met okay so you
can definitely suggest and say listen
out of the thousand applications that
this position received you know these
fifty profiles you know have seemed to
have all the right kinds of things that
are related to this job based on the
information I've seen from other jobs
you know we think that's gonna be a
useful feature so we are working on that
go ahead yes absolutely yes so this for
this to work the similarity that we
define between candidates does rely on
you having having the structured data
absolutely could you go and say alright
just look at the profile as just raw
text right and just start computing sort
of you know do cosine similarity just
put it in a vector space and start doing
some some cosine similarity we've
actually tried that it works better if
you've if you've structured it far
better
now that's an excellent question okay so
the basic the basic idea here of course
it privacy is a massive it is a massive
issue so it's why I didn't show you
actually real-life Seavey's from people
who have applied the the main the main
answer here is that you need whatever
algorithm that you develop right so the
ownership of the data is with the
individual clients right if you apply to
client a and you also apply to client be
in our database client a has absolutely
no knowledge of what you're doing with
client be in vice versa of course now if
you use the information that you have
right about you the fact that you apply
to collide a and client B using an
approach as I described so something
similar to collaborative filtering or
Content matching or whatever these
generally preserve privacy right because
essentially you having applied to
candidate to client a and client B just
adds a counter somewhere right so you're
just modifying certain numbers so we
feel that you know it's it's perfectly
fair to do this right I mean we were
seeing sort of behavior and sort of
counting things and that doesn't really
break anybody's privacy because none of
your individual information ends up
being shown
I'm nor will it to do somebody else
right oh okay yes yeah yeah yeah
well our machines have sound and yes yes
so certainly they part they certainly
they add to our training data for
algorithms in that sense yes in that
sense yes we do use data to actually
train and to see examples
that's that's an interesting question I
am I think that there is a well there is
there is a certain amount of pressure
and it's called LinkedIn for there's a
me ultimately it's it's I would say I'm
not sure globally but certainly to a
large many places it's it's the de facto
standard for maintaining sort of your
your details I'm I maintain for exam I'm
maintaining my LinkedIn profile a lot
more frequently than I maintain my sort
of sitting right sort of on a CV right I
think that I mean it's this thing
exactly because it spans it applies to
everybody right it spans all industries
all individuals establishing
establishing any sort of convention is
very difficult within a single community
trying to doing it across the world I
think it's it's very difficult I think
if you ask me in terms of direction I
think that over time I strongly believe
that we reliance on CVS is going to
diminish not so much in terms of the
concept of a CV but basically the a
person's online footprint is going to
grow over time
because there is you know also from the
perspective of if you think of how
people hire today it was an example
given sort of for a developer in an
earlier talk to sort of a developer
knowing their github profile and knowing
that they have contributed to an open
source java project for example would
say that native probably there is
something about java and that they're
active and whatever similar thing with
knowing sort of where they blog and
knowing what they tweet about things
like that that they name themselves make
public and I think that there's going to
be a large move towards taking and
leveraging that information to establish
online profiles that will essentially
remove the requirement two-part series
nonetheless
one interesting thing I would say is
that a lot of the techniques that we're
doing here that have to do with
correctly identifying entities in text
understanding sort of this processing
that we do still applies because we've
seen I've seen lots and lots of LinkedIn
profiles where even though the person
filling them in was told the names of
the fields that
what they should be filling in you go
and you analyze the proform you see
there's you know there are a lot of
things that are mixed non-standard
errors and whatever so a lot of the
stuff even translates to a structured
profiles as well so okay I don't know if
that answered your question but I hope
it did thank you it was a privilege to
be here
you